tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel italie
un commando de brigades rouges attaque
le siège de la démocratie chrétienne en
plein coeur de rome et tue un policier
le gouvernement français et le comité
olympique international
d'accord la tournée des springboks ce
doit être annulée françois mitterrand
les responsables parlementaires de la
majorité reçus à l'elysée le président
de la république a évoqué avec eux ces
entretiens de moscou les remous au rpr
il n'y a pas de complot affirme olivier
guichard qui a réuni ce matin 26 députés
du rassemblement
bonsoir au moment où les pays européens
de la communauté sont engagés dans un
débat parfois profonds parfois
académique sur leur avenir face à la
crise de l'énergie surtout un débat qui
concerne aussi l'avenir de la démocratie
d'ailleurs deux des pays du marché
commun sont en période électorale
nationale
avant d'entamer une campagne pour les
élections européennes le 10 juin en
grande-bretagne
c'est aujourd'hui que l'on vote nous en
parlerons tout à l'heure et en italie
c'est aujourd'hui que s'ouvrait la
campagne pour les élections anticipées
législatives qui auront lieu le 3 juin
et là on se souvient tout à coup qu'il
existe aussi une europe de la violence
en effet pour ce premier jour de la
campagne électorale italienne c'est un
véritable commando de huit à dix
personnes des brigades rouges qui a
attaqué ce matin en plein centre de rome
le siège provincial du parti de la
démocratie chrétienne une véritable
action de guerre comme le disait bien
d'ailleurs une inscription laissé sur
place sur les murs transformer la
tromperie électorale en guerre de classe
le commando a fait sauter plusieurs
charges d'explosif et avant de s'enfuir
par les terrasses il a tiré sur la
première voiture de policiers qui s'est
présentée un policier est mort
et deux autres ont été grièvement
blessés inutile d'ajouter que cet
attentat en plein jour en plein centre
de rome
on veut qu une vive émotion en italie où
l'année pourtant habitué hélas aux
attentats politiques club brevets vie
plus encore que l'émotion celle angoisse
qui a repris les italiens après ce
terrifiant coup de main en plein jour et
au coeur de rome une peut retrouver pour
la première fois depuis l'affairé aldo
moro
il ya juste un an un coup très grave qui
en quelques secondes ce matin a réussi à
déstabiliser l'italie à peine engagé
dans la campagne électorale
c'est ce que voulait le commando des
brigades rouges à partir de maintenant
et jusqu'au 10 juin
aucun meeting électoral aucun siège de
parti
aucun homme politique ne se sentira en
sécurité en italie chacun attendant dans
la crainte
le prochain objectif de l'organisation
terroriste c'est dire si les dizaines
d'arrestations qui ont fait grand bruit
ces derniers temps notamment dans les
milieux de gauche de l'université de
padoue paraissent dérisoires
quant à la réorganisation des services
de police elle demeure inefficace face à
quelques poignées de terroristes qui
vont continuer de toute évidence à faire
trembler l'italie le pays certes s'est
habituée aux attentats quotidiens et les
assimile même avec un étonnant fatalisme
mais il faut se demander comment
réagiront les italiens lorsque l'
escalade impuni de la violence aura été
trop loin en grande bretagne aucun
incident heureusement à signaler depuis
le début du scrutin
à 7h ce matin les électeurs britanniques
ont jusqu'à 22 heures pour voter
la journée n'est pas chaud mais je vous
le rappelle est au vote avant de partir
au travail ou en en revenant
les résultats ne seront connus que
demain dans la matinée mais 17me nous
aurons ce qu'on appelle des fourchettes
sur les possibles résultats les derniers
sondages en tout cas semblé donner les
conservateurs légèrement favoris les
votes aujourd'hui jusqu'à 10 heures du
soir 41 millions de sujets du royaume
uni vont aux urnes
à l'exception de la reine de la famille
royale et des membres de la chambre dès
lors il y avait des files d'attentes
cela ne s'était jamais vu les bookmakers
ont glané trois millions de livres cela
ne s'est pas loin de 30 millions de nos
francs
il donne ma greffe cher leader des
conservateurs gagnante à la bourse
l'indicateur de tendance à gagner
aujourd'hui près de 10 points les
sondages il y en a encore aujourd'hui
dont aussi madame thatcher en tête avec
20 à 60 sièges d'avancé
la presse de ce soir chante presque sa
victoire vient de dire je ne compte pas
mes poulets avant qu'il n'ait clause est
la raison d'être prudente car en 1970
c'est le parti donné perdant par les
sondages qui a gagné la bbc et la
télévision privée vont diffuser les
résultats pratiquement toutes les nuits
il est raisonnable de penser pearl on
sera fixé demain en fin de matinée la
journée politique à paris en tout cas à
l'elysée et à l'assemblée nationale
était entièrement placée sous le signe
de la politique étrangère de la france
d'une part le président de la république
a reçu toute la journée les leaders
politiques pour leur parler de ces
conversations récentes avec monsieur
brejnev et les autres dirigeants
soviétiques
d'autre part à l'assemblée nationale il
y avait un débat de politique étrangère
cependant et c'était sans doute
inévitable
les autres tient de l'elysée ont eu des
retombées encore flou sur les tensions
politiques internes et d'abord parce que
françois mitterrand est venu avec une
délégation socialiste au rendez-vous de
l'elysée un rendez-vous que georges
marchais avait refusé les entretiens
l'elysée avait commencé au petit
déjeuner avec les présidents des
commissions des affaires étrangères de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
donc nos risques ou de murville et jean
lecanuet puis c'était les présidents des
groupes de la majorité des deux chambres
claude labbé et roger chinaud pour
l'assemblée adolphe chauvin et marc
jacquet pour le sénat venir à fort
bloqué ses visiteurs n'a levé le secret
sur ce que leur avait dit de prison la
république
enfin en début d'après midi c'était une
conversation d'une heure entre monsieur
giscard d'estaing et françois mitterrand
accompagné notamment du numéro deux du
parti socialiste lionel jospin sur le
perron france à mi terrain commençait a
confié aux journalistes qu'il avait été
question de la dea
tente de la coexistence et de la
sécurité collective quand on arrivait du
premier ministre mauritanien pour une
audience chez le président provoqua une
bousculade
monsieur mitterrand submergé par les
micros préféra alors donné rendez vous
en fin d'après midi au siège du parti
socialiste aux journalistes pour son
commentaire sur cette visite
commentaires que vous allez entendre
maintenant au parti socialiste
mieux
option
il n'y a pas eu le moindre mot touchante
à la politique intérieure
sinon qu'à la fin de notre entretien
j'ai précisément que de voir souligné
que l'eau bouger mam de cet entretien
les relations franco soviétique se
suffisait à lui-même mais que toute
autre circonstance et sur tout autre
sujet le parti socialiste ne manquerait
pas de faire valoir ses objections à la
politique du gouvernement et à celle du
président de la république mais enfin
obéissant aux lois du genre lorsqu'il
s'agit de représenter les intérêts de la
france par rapport à l'un des plus
puissants pays du monde auquel nuit
toute une histoire et qui représente un
facteur essentiel de la peine
aujourd'hui et demain
je pense que ce sujet suffi à remplir
une bonne heure en tirer la conséquence
qu'il y aurait comme vous ne le faire
comme une sorte de détente
les relations entre eux le président la
vie j'ai failli dire le président de
l'udf meneur de la liste barbell bien
entendu ce n'était pas le sujet de la
conversation
mais nul ne pouvait se méprendre
parmi ceux qui s'entretenait de
politique étrangère dans le cadre fixé
de relation que l'on doit avoir dans une
démocratie
dès lors qu'il s'agit des intérêts
fondamentaux d'un pays qui nous est
commun pour le risque
comment imaginer moindre confusion
tandis que françois mitterrand était à
l'elysée une autre personnalité
socialiste gaston defferre rencontré le
premier ministre raymond barre l'hôtel
matignon pour lui remettre un mémorandum
socialiste en 15 points sur
l'organisation de la campagne pour les
élections européennes
les propositions socialistes concernait
l'organisation des missions et de débat
à la radio télévision
d
sion vivante et pédagogique précisé
gaston defferre de véritables débats sur
des sujets concrets est déterminant pour
l'avenir et ils réclamaient aussi une
campagne officielle strictement
équilibrée ainsi que la publication et
le contrôle des dépenses électorales des
partis politiques
alors après cet entretien avec le
premier ministre gaston defferre s'est
montré désabusé pris date et nous allons
voir comment les choses se passeront
dans la campagne électorale et après la
campagne nous pour faire une sur deux
tableaux pour comparer ce qui aura été
fait par rapport à ce que nous avions
demandé et nous pourrons dire au
gouvernement qui ne s'est pas comporté
d'une façon démocratique car je ne doute
pas que cette fois ci puisque dans le
passé nos gouvernements acceptent de
respecter des droits d'opposition je
suis convaincu qu'il ne respectera pas
davantage aujourd'hui
pierre olivier guichard toujours
considéré comme l'un des barons du
gaullisme avait confié avait convié
pardo par lettre une soixantaine de
députés rpr à venir parler avec lui aux
réunions privées des élections
européennes et des problèmes que posait
au groupe la stratégie très offensive de
jacques chirac
vingt six députés sur les 60 qui avaient
été invités sont venus à cette réunion
en se défendant d'ailleurs de vouloir
participer à une opération
fractionnistes c'est robert poujade
député de la côte d'or et ancien
ministre qui a fait remarquer non sans
humour et même avec beaucoup d'humour
qu'au dessous de 43 participants une
réunion n'était pas subversives
allusion évidente à l'initiative de
jacques chirac de réunir 43 députés udf
en 74 en faveur de monsieur giscard
d'estaing et non de monsieur chaban
delmas à l'époque vous allez entendre
les explications d'olivier guichard sur
cette réunion puis l'opinion de claude
labbé bras droit de jacques chirac
opinion donné aux journalistes après sa
visite à l'elysée d'abord olivier
guichard
monsieur nice et rennes vous année aux
affaires vous accuse d'être
infractionnistes que répondez vous à
cela
perdre et j'ai pris soin en invitant
quelques amis ce matin à venir discuter
autour d'un verre chez moi de l'épargné
qui ne s'agir quelques entreprises
fractionnement je suis depuis toujours
et je l'éprouvé croyez-moi ça attachés à
l'unité du groupe mais je pense aussi
qu'il n'est pas vrai qu'on puisse de
talent autant discuter ensemble et comme
beaucoup de collègues elle est suggéré
de faire nous sommes réunis à
quelques-uns et ils vont revenir à
quelques autres du reste pour expliquer
les problèmes
la politique d'aujourd'hui c'est une
ce n'est pas une manifestation c'était
une invitation qu'elle espérait et
garder un caractère secret et je vous
avoue que quand même cet avion n'est
donné du hockey un communiqué je ne
comptais pas répondre à vos questions si
de mauvaises intentions matin avait été
évoquée par d'autres c'est la division
agents pensent le plus grand mal je n'ai
d'ailleurs dit car je crois que toute
opération fractionnistes même si elles
ne partent pas de mauvaises intentions
correspond une espèce de confusion dans
l'opinion publique qui est de toute
façon détestable et en fait ce genre de
manifestation se retourne toujours
contre ceux qui les organisent
voilà nos de l'abbé ne pas commenter le
fait que jacques chirac n'ait pas été
convié à l'elysée
d'autre part jacques chirac rentrée
aujourd'hui du canada n'a pas commenté
non plus la réunion organisée par
olivier guichard pour boucler la boucle
sur la politique et les élections
européennes je citerai encore ce propos
de raymond barre devant l'association
internationale des anciens des
communautés européennes oui ça existe
il a souhaité le premier ministre que
les français sachent s'élever au dessus
des débats médiocre et subalternes
pendant la campagne est ici un sondage
un sondage sofres qui paraîtra dans le
figaro de demain matin il concerne les
intentions de vote bien sûr et on y voit
les tendances s'affirment et pour les
élections européennes la liste de simone
veil obtient 30% des voix de faire des
intentions de vote
quatre points de plus qu'il ya quinze
jours la liste françois mitterrand 26%
la liste marchait 19% la liste chirac
debré 17% trois points de moins par
rapport au précédent sondage
à noter qu'il ya encore 33 % d'indécis
dont 39% de sympathisants rpr à
l'assemblée nationale le ministre des
affaires étrangères jean françois poncet
a donc engagé cet après midi le débat de
politique étrangère un débat sans vote
je le précise jean françois poncet a
rappelé quels étaient les quatre piliers
de la politique extérieure de la france
maintenir la paix en dépit de
multiplication des foyers de tension
dans le monde faire prévaloir la
coopération sur l'affrontement dans les
relations économiques internationales
organisées l'europe ça on le sait
assurer le rayonnement d'une france
indépendante et généreuse bien entendu
avant tout la détente reste la clé de la
paix par ailleurs en ce qui concerne le
proche orient la france n'est ni hostile
ni opposés à l'accord de paix entre
l'egypte et israël simplement on fait
remarquer une fois de plus que cela
n'aboutira pas forcément au règlement
global indispensable notamment pour
l'avenir du peuple palestinien et en ce
qui concerne l'iran la france qui ne
regrette certainement pas d'avoir
accueilli l'ayatollah khomeini sur son
territoire déplore tout de même les
excès de la révolution mais dans le
discours de jean françois-poncet y avait
surtout l'europe
une trentaine d'interventions sont onze
étaient prévues dans ce débat dont
jacques hébert nous rend compte à cinq
semaines des élections européennes
à quoi donc peut bien penser un député
si ce n'est à l'europe et sur ce thème
le dialogue de sourds engagée depuis
quelques mois a continué cet après-midi
dans l'hémicycle
parfois devant seulement une vingtaine
de députés il y avait un côté le
ministre des affaires étrangères qui
fixe comme objectif prioritaire
l'organisation de l'europe pour
surmonter la crise économique
s'adressant indirectement à jacques
chirac mais aussi à michel debré jean
françois poncet aura cette phrase la
fermeté n'exige pas l'éclat pourquoi
dire que là où il n'y a ni fracas ni
portes claquées ni chaise abandonné il y
aurait obligatoirement complaisance
faiblesse et renoncement c'est ensuite
maurice couve de murville qui pour le
rpr répète qu'il ya toujours de façon de
lire à traiter notamment le traité de
rome maurice couve de murville
regrettera et ceci est aussi adressée à
jacques chirac que tout tourne à une
détestable affaire de politique
intérieure pour les communistes c'est
maxime gremetz ceux qui déclarent que le
gouvernement entraîne le pays vers le
déclin dans un empire germano-américain
pour l'udf cerner fake qui appellera à
la vigilance du gouvernement tout en se
prononçant favorablement pour
l'élargissement de la communauté
enfin c'est pour les deux socialistes
jean-pierre cot qui donne trois
définitions l'europe des marchands
celles du gouvernement
l'europe des nationalistes celle du rpr
et du parti communiste et l'europe des
travailleurs celle du parti socialiste
le débat doit se poursuivre tard dans la
nuit je vous rappelle qu'il ne sera pas
sanctionné par un vote
il est devenu impossible de parler de
politique étrangère politique
internationale sont discuter de la crise
de l'énergie et du pétrole et en france
le problème a été aussi évoquée
plusieurs fois à l'assemblée nationale
ces temps ci monsieur giraud répète
aussi depuis plusieurs semaines qu'il
n'est pas question d'instituer un
rationnement en france
le ministre reconnaît néanmoins qu'il
existe des difficultés de livraison sur
le gazole notamment en ce moment dans le
sud ouest
en revanche aux états unis des
américains commençaient à souffrir d'une
relative pénurie de carburant je dis
bien relative
de plus les pompistes américains ont
décidé une grève dans quinze jours
pendant tout le week end pour obtenir
une augmentation de leurs tarifs le
point alors sur le problème de l'essence
aux états unis avec emmanuel de la
taille
imaginez en france que l'on parle de
tickets de rationnement ce serait la
panique et la ruée sur les pompes
paradoxalement il n'en est rien aux
états unis le pays pourtant le plus
glouton carburant quand le président
carter cherche à mobiliser ses
compatriotes pour un plan d'urgence en
cas de pénurie d'essence avec flegme les
américains aussi habitué aux
contrariétés co gaspillage ne s'affole
pas en voyant les stations d'imiter les
remplissages le super encore à 90
centimes le litre ou fermée le week end
les raisons de cette situation la crise
en iran où l'amérique à notre différence
fournissait largement a réduit
l'approvisionnement mondial de 2% alors
que la consommation augmente de 4 il y a
donc une légère pénurie de pétrole que
les producteurs entretiennent pour faire
monter les prix du coup les grandes
compagnies américaines qui cherchent à
maintenir leurs stocks pour l'été ont
réduit de 15 à 20 % leurs livraisons et
les pompes répercute aux clients qui
roule un peu moins le président carter
utilisent cette menace de pénurie pour
contraindre le congrès d'adopter son
programme d'économie d'énergie
un programme qui nous concerne en france
avec 7 % de la population mondiale
l'amérique consomme le tiers de l'or
noir du monde trois fois plus par
personne que l'europe au moment où l'on
peut s'attendre à quelques difficultés
d'approvisionnement cet hiver
tout effort des américains pour limiter
leur consommation de pétrole en laisse
un peu plus aux autres donc à nous
envoyer le tifo l'expérience politique
encore politique et sport cette fois les
rugbymen sud-africains ne viendront pas
faire leur tournée en france à l'automne
prochain
ainsi en a décidé le gouvernement
français malgré l'avis contraire du
comité des sports national jean pierre
soisson le ministre de la jeunesse et
des sports l'a dit ce matin
nous ne pouvons pas adopter une
politique qui nous couperait des pays
africains inutile de vous rappeler que
l'afrique du sud est condamné pour sa
politique raciale c'est pourquoi une
réunion entre les représentants du
ministère des affaires étrangères de
l'intérieur de la jeunesse et des sports
va très vite
étudier les modalités qui vont empêcher
effectivement la tournée des springboks
ce en france je vous propose d'écouter
successivement jean pierre soisson
puis lorsqu'il hanine le président du
comité olympique international venu à
paris pour une remise de prix de
l'académie des sports gouvernement
français juge inopportune la venue d'
équipe d'afrique du sud en france
il l'a déclaré à l'assemblée nationale
par la voix du ministre des affaires
étrangères et il le réaffirme
aujourd'hui par me voient ils nous
auront à étudier les modalités dans
laquelle cette décision du gouvernement
devra intervenir
j'ajoute que je ne souhaite pas que le
mouvement sportif français se coupe du
mouvement sportif international
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'attache aujourd'hui le plus grand prix
à la visite du président et du cio en
france dans la sphère des rugbymen
sud-africains
s'il venait en france vraiment il se
pourrait que la france soit exclu les
jeux olympiques
et bien tout ne semble pas subir mais si
le mouvement point de vue se tourner
c'est tatiana porte une à ce moment
oui la tournée est inopportune en ce
moment le comité olympique français qui
ne veut s'occuper que de sport
s'inclinera devant la décision politique
mais lord killanin dit également qu'à
l'étranger on qualifiait de raciste
l'attitude des dirigeants qui encourage
à l'avenir les springbocks en france ces
paroles n'ont pas plus bien sûr aux
olympiques français qui vont écrire au
président du cio pour préciser leurs
attitudes et explique en particulier aux
pays africains qu'elle n'a rien de
raciste et qui vont étendre leur
réflexion olympienne pour éviter la
politisation du mouvement sportif
il envisage de proposer par exemple que
les jeux pour rester à l'abri de toute
influence se déroule en territoire
neutre quelque part en grèce pour faire
revivre tous les quatre ans une
véritable trêve olympique comme dans
l'antiquité
oui une sorte de retour la tradition
donc est une tradition qui à l'époque à
l'époque de la grèce convient d'évoquer
n'empêchait pas pour autant les conflits
jean claude narcy les autres nouvelles
de ce journal oui en iran d'abord où
toute activité a été interrompue
aujourd'hui c'était la journée de deuil
national à l'occasion des obsèques de
l'ayatollah motahari le premier chef
religieux assassinés depuis la
révolution
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes défilaient ce matin dans les
rues de téhéran
les funérailles se sont d'ailleurs
transformée en véritable manifestation
anti communiste l'organisation
extrémiste
morgan qui a revendiqué cet attentat a
également menacé aujourd'hui de morts
quatre autres collaborateurs de
l'ayatollah khomeini situation tendue à
la frontière sino vietnamienne ou en dix
jours 14 incidents armés ont opposé les
forces des deux pays pcar menace de
donner une nouvelle leçon au vietnam
hanoi accusent la chine d'agression est
d'ailleurs ce soir le conflit sino
vietnamien sera au sommaire du magazine
à 21h30 avec un document exceptionnel le
premier film chinois tourné pendant
l'opération chinoise il ya deux mois
vous verrez également le témoignage
l'envoyé spécial de tf1 françois debré
qui revient de la frontière où il a pu
étudier la situation du côté chinois
un autre document dans l'événement il
est signé jean bertolino à naga des en
iran il a été le seul témoin occidentale
des combats qui ont fait plus de 800
morts entre le 20 et le 25 avril dernier
qui opposait les habitants d'origine
tueur aux kurdes donc à 21h30 ce soir
dans l'événement le magazine d'hugh
laurie marque christian bernadac et
julien besançon le colonel mohamed ould
bousseif le premier ministre mauritanien
est arrivé à paris aujourd'hui pour une
visite de deux jours à l'invitation de
raymond barre qui l'a rencontré cet
après midi ainsi que le président de la
république c'est une prise de contact
pour le nouveau gouvernement mauritanien
au programme des discussions avec le
président valéry giscard d'estaing les
problèmes du sahara occidental bien sûr
elad française la mauritanie pour
assurer la défense contre les maquisards
sahraouis élections européennes le ps a
décidé de présenter sa propre liste elle
est conduite par huguette bouchardeau et
charles piaget le militant syndicaliste
cfdt la ligue communiste révolutionnaire
et lutte ouvrière ces deux organes deux
organisations entre ce kyste feront
liste commune et elle sera conduite par
arlette laguiller et alain krivine enfin
l'extrême droite elle se présentera sous
le sigle l'union française pour l'euro
droite des patries et jean marie le pen
pascal gauchon michel de saint pierre
ont dénoncé cet après-midi dans une
conférence de presse le fameux barrage
des 5% de la loi électorale qui est
selon eux contraire à l'esprit même du
scrutin proportionnel à fos sur mer une
compagnie de crs est intervenue en fin
de matinée dans l'enceinte de l'usiné
sidérurgique sol mer pour libérer le
directeur usine qui étaient séquestrés
par des employés l'intervention s'est
déroulée sans incident la majorité des
sidérurgistes d'usinor longwood qui ont
participé ce matin à la consultation
organisée par les syndicats cgt ont
décidé de poursuivre l'occupation lusine
engagée vendredi dernier à la suite
d'une grève à l'aciérie 1
lle environ 2 d'employés sur les 7850 de
l'entreprise ont participé à ce vote
le travail clandestin ça peut finir très
mal c'est le thème d'une campagne
nationale contre le travail au noir a
lancé par le secrétaire d'état le
secrétariat d'état à la condition des
travailleurs manuels 500 mille affiches
des spots à la radio à la télévision on
s'efforçait de convaincre l'opinion de
ce mal social que représente le travail
noir en période de chômage
les négociations sur les vols vacances
vers les états unis ont abouti et à
france dès cet été va proposer des
allers retours de 1800 francs en basse
saison je parle pour new york et 2003 en
haute saison sera pour cela rester plus
de quatorze jours aux états unis
et puis acheter le billet dès la
réservation à la suite des incidents qui
ont marqué la fin de la manifestation du
1er mai à paris vous en souvenez cinq
jeunes gens comparent et c'est
aujourd'hui en flagrant délit cet après
midi et bien ils ont été mis en liberté
et les débats sont envoyés au 28 juin
prochain
400 millions de francs dissimulé au fisc
trente trois inculpés tous libres
d'ailleurs de nombreuses faillites des
escroqueries cinq ans d'information
judiciaire voilà ce qui se jugent depuis
ce matin en correctionnelle à paris
les débats vont durer jusqu'en juillet
la molette de ce procès samuel flattot
sharon le député israélien qui sera jugé
par défaut comme plusieurs de ses
complices
flattot sharon a révélé aujourd'hui
agence france presse qu'il avait demandé
à la france a sauf conduit il ya
quelques temps lui permettant de se
présenter lui même à ce procès mais qui
n'a pas encore de réponse alors dans
l'état actuel des choses il est sous le
coup d'un mandat d'arrêt donc si vous
venez en france et bien il serait arrêté
immédiatement un détenu tué et quatre
blessés cet après midi lors d'une
tentative d'évasion de la prison de
fleury mérogis la prison dans l'essonne
c'est un complice venus de l'extérieur
déguisé en chauffeur livreur qui a
fourni les armes aux détenus il y eu
bail avec les gendarmes qui ont rattrapé
les fuyards tuant l'un d'entre eux
blessant et trois autres le complice lui
aussi couchera mais ce soir en prison
enfin si vous avez jour le taux pour
gagner il fallait jouer le 8 le 17
le 21 le 32 le 33 et le 36 avec un
numéro complémentaire le 23 comme vous
l'avez sur votre écran le temps eh bien
on grelotte toujours sur la moitié nord
mais c'est dans toute l'europe de brest
à varsovie d'oslo à vienne pourtant
moscou est privilégiée
22 degrés et il fait plutôt bon dans
l'europe du sud chez nous en tout cas
les températures sont comme on dit bien
basses pour la saison comme vous pouvez
en juger même chose demain il y aura
encore des gelées de l'intérieur l'otan
sera toujours aussi variable avec
peut-être une toute petite amélioration
mais toujours des averses accompagnées
de neige ou de graines un peu partout
les éclaircies les plus belles auront
lieu le matin sur le sud ouest et
l'après midi autour de la méditerranée
et encore des rafales de vent demain à
prévoir sur les côtes de la manche et de
la mer du nord
mistral également bien installée dans le
midi pour la bonne soirée à tous au nom
de et à toutes
au nom de toute l'équipe de tf1
actualité le dernier journal avec
jacques nouard en fin de programme
à 22h35 merci